[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo 30 minutes pour refaire ensemble
la semaine politique et parlementaire
une semaine intense au parlement et à
mes côtés kathia gilder au genre katia
bourges où henri année nous accueillons
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau guillaume
larrivé bonjour merci d'eric nous est
député les républicains de l'yonne vous
avez été réélu en juin dernier
eh bien on va revoir avec vous tout de
suite les images de la semaine avec
cette séance inédite à l'assemblée la
bataille pour les postes créés au palais
bourbon a fait rage emmanuel macron lui
sera à versailles devant les députés et
sénateurs réunis en congrès deuxième
image forte de la semaine et puis le
coup d'envoi de la réforme du code du
travail le projet de loi qui habilite le
gouvernement a changé le droit par
ordonnance est à l'assemblée dès mardi
soir et on commence avec ce scénario
inédit et inattendu cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la répartition des fonctions clés à
l'assemblée a tourné au psychodrame l'un
des trois postes de questeur
traditionnellement réservé à
l'opposition a été attribué un
républicain constructif thierry solère
christian jacob le président du groupe
l'est républicain a dénoncé une atteinte
aux droits de l'opposition mari la bat
l'élection avait duré moins de cinq
minutes en 2012 elle aura pris près de
10 hier soir six vice-présidents c'est
surtout trois postes de questeur sont
alors mises en jeu dans l'hémicycle une
formalité puisque usuellement la
répartition de ces postes clés se fait
en amont lors de la réunion des
présidents de groupe de poste de
questeur vont alors à la majorité 1 à
l'opposition pourtant au moment de
l'élection coup théâtre monsieur florian
bacheliers madame lauriane rossi et
monsieur thierry solère ayant obtenu la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
je les proclame questeur de l'assemblée
nationale membre dé constructif
un groupe minoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale thierry solère vient d'être
élu grâce à l'appui de députés de la
majorité présidentielle pour christian
jacob président du principal groupe
d'opposition
c'est un déni de démocratie monsieur le
président on vient de rompre avec plus
de 50 ans de pratique parlementaire les
droits de l'opposition viennent d'être
bafoués comme ils n'ont jamais été
bafoués dans cet hémicycle
c'est là c'est la majorité qui
choisissent en opposition ça n'était
jamais arrivé dans l'hémicycle c'est la
confusion générale françois de rugy tout
nouveau président de l'assemblée
nationale est alors obligé de réclamer
une suspension de séance
christian jacob menace tant que les
droits de l'opposition ne seront pas
rétablis les républicains refuseront de
siéger au bureau de l'assemblée
une démarche soutenue par une partie de
la gauche qu'est ce que c'est que cette
façon de fonctionner est ce que c'est ça
la nouveauté est ce que vous allez faire
la démonstration ce soir que sur six
vice présidents
il donnera cinq qui seront les
vice-présidents du rouleau compresseur
au nom de quelle
de quelle démocratie quelle image vous
donner de notre assemblée
la promesse cette élection
présidentielle les élections initiatives
qui ont suivi c'était d'entrer dans un
nouveau monde dans lequel nouveau monde
sommes-nous désormais c'est le moment
que choisit alors jean-luc mélenchon
pour déposer une candidature de son
groupe à la vice-présidence elle est
suivie de trois autres avec dix
candidats pour six postes
il faut donc un nouveau vote à minuit et
demi le résultat tombe cinq républiques
en marche et un modem sont désignés vice
président les trois postes de questeur
reste aux deux députés de la majorité
présidentielle et à thierry solère alors
revenons sur ce qui s'est passé
guillaume larrivé vous avez au mans 2-2
cela twitté quelque chose la majorité va
jusqu'à choisir son opposition
officielle ou contester cette élection
poste de questeur de thierry solère
c'est ça toujours vous l'a contesté
toujours pour vous il a chipé le poste
de questeur le sujet c'est pas du tout
une bataille de postes une bataille de
titres ça serait accessoires il ya un
vrai sujet de fond les droits le groupe
en marche c'est le groupe entièrement
dans la main de l'elysée
on l'a vu d'ailleurs la semaine d'avant
lorsque le président de ce groupe a été
quasiment nommé par l'elysée à main
levée par acclamation et c'est ce groupe
en marche qui cette semaine a choisi les
trois personnes chargées de gérer les
finances les comptes de l'assemblée donc
la main de l'elysée est au soir en
réalité une prise de contrôle de
l'assemblée nationale par l'elysée
aujourd'hui l'opposition libre n'a aucun
droit de regard sur les finances de
l'assemblée nationale c'est ça le sujet
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
préoccupant
on assiste à la prise de contrôle totale
de l'assemblée nationale s'était
complètement organiser le pouvoir
organiser résidentiel et pourquoi est-ce
que ça a été possible parce que avec une
certaine habileté
en réalité il ya un petit groupe qui
s'est constitué qui fait semblant d'être
dans l'opposition mais qui en réalité
dans la majorité souhaitaient une espèce
de petite tambouille penser
un groupe se dope constructif en réalité
le groupe et l'on vous thierry solère à
l'elysée hammett est ce que thierry
solère a menti à son groupe c'est ce que
disent et se dit christian jacob
la question de savoir ce que fait l
hôtel de mes collègues je pas là pour
commenter les oeuvres la vie glorieuse
de monsieur quand même ça que thierry
s'inscrit dans l'opposition et au final
vous dites qu'il est non mais ça sent
marche en bout le vrai sujet de fond le
sujet institutionnel c'est que ce
quinquennat commence avec une prise de
contrôle totale de l'assemblée nationale
par l'elysée c'est vrai pour ce qu'on
appelle la questure c'est à dire cette
fonction de contrôle des finances de
l'assemblée
c'est vrai aussi pour les vice
présidents de l'assemblée nationale et
la majorité un président de la malle six
vice-présidents les six vice-présidents
sont entièrement 1 en marche au modem
c'est à dire dans la majorité
présidentielle
et c'est tout à fait nouveau sous
françois mitterrand sous jacques chirac
sous nicolas sarkozy sous valéry giscard
d'estaing
il y avait un pluralisme à l'assemblée
et vous savez je crois pas du tout que
cet être moderne c'est pas du tout est
dans le nouveau monde que de piétiner
les droits de l'opposition parce que ici
nous sommes l'assemblée nationale nous
sommes les représentants du peuple
français
nous sommes des députés libres et nous
ne sommes pas des gens qui devront être
aux ordres du nouveau prince élyséen et
les maquereaux est-ce que vous pensez
que ce qu'il s'est passé est vraiment la
responsabilité de l'elysée où est ce que
ce n'est pas la conséquence de la guerre
des droites pas du tout le vrai sujet
c'est l'organisation depuis l'élection
d' emmanuel macron d'une situation qui
permet la prise de contrôle de tous les
pouvoirs par le pouvoir présidentiel
ils jouent pour cela d'un certain nombre
d'évolutions de l'organisation de
l'assemblée
voyez ce que je veux dire une certaine
désorganisation à certains égards on le
voit bien il ya vécu du cafouillage à
part du président de rugy en application
du règlement était très incertaine et
d'ailleurs je trouve très bien que lui d
y ait saisi le conseil constitutionnel
car l'application du règlement va
contraindre la technique c'est des
articles 10 25 et 26 du règlement
l'application du règlement de la salle
c'est à dire des règles du jeu a été
extrêmement aléatoires et créative ces
derniers jours il serait temps
d'ailleurs que françois de rugy ce matin
qui peut à potasser le règlement de
l'assemblée
pour éviter de faire n'importe quoi
lorsqu'il présidait la séance alors on
va aller plus loin sur ce thème
stéphanie
a rejoint bonjour bonjour vous avez
suivi tout ça vous suivez la droite
alors expliquez nous est ce que la
guerre des droites et déclaré oui alors
cette fois ça semble clair aurait vu
public un la guerre est déclarée alors
avant bien sûr il ya eu plusieurs
épisodes qui ont fait monter la tension
tout commence évidemment quand bruno le
maire ses proches et les juppéiste
quittant avec fracas la campagne de
françois fillon début mars alors que le
candidat à la présidentielle est mise en
examen ensuite en mai il ya la
nomination d'edouard philippe comme
premier ministre puis celle de bruno le
maire et gérald darmanin à l'économie et
au budget une trahison selon bon nombre
d'élus les républicains à l'assemblée la
semaine dernière c'est la création du
nouveau groupe les constructif qui a
marqué un point de rupture entre la
quinzaine de députés aient l'air
constructif et leurs collègues restés et
l'ère canal historique si on peut dire
alors autant vous dire que l'élection de
thierry solère à la questure mercredi à
la place d'eric ciotti a définitivement
mis le feu aux poudres
jusqu'à mercredi le mot d'ordre chez les
républicains canal historique s'était
officiellement pas d'invectivés contrôle
et constructif
aujourd'hui ils sont outrés par ce coup
de poker de thierry solère et tire à
boulet rouge sur le député des
hauts-de-seine on l'entend du guillaume
larrivé vous dénonciez à une fausse
opposition et bien c'était la ligne
aussi de christian jacob le patron des
députés et l'eire qui dénonce un faux
nez de l'opposition eric ciotti lui le
député des alpes maritimes rappelle
cette semaine à longueur d'interviews
que thierry solère a fait l'objet d'une
enquête fait l'objet pardon d'une
enquête préliminaire pour fraude fiscale
et ses fans et le prochain épisode pour
le parti républicain ce sera le 11
juillet le prochain bureau politique
il s'annonce tendu on imagine et oui
tendues depuis des semaines les tenant
de la ligne dure du parti les
républicains réclament l'exclusion dé
constructif mais jusqu'ici aucun
dirigeant du parti n'avaient clairement
évoqué cette hypothèse
et hier jeudi le secrétaire général du
parti bernard accoyer annonce que leur
exclusion sera donc au menu du bureau
politique le 11 juillet vu la
composition du bureau l'exclusion ne
fait guère de doute et elle devrait
concerner donc les quatre républicains
qui ont rejoint le gouvernement edouard
philippe gérald darmanin bruno le maire
est sébastien lecornu donc thierry
solère et franck riester aussi du côté
des députés mais peut-être pas tous les
députés constructif
certains élus aient l'air n'écarte pas
en effet l'idée de voir revenir certains
constructif danger
rangs du parti à l'assemblée si
l'expérience n'est pas concluante
en revanche d'autres députés constructif
disent que si l'expérience de ce nouveau
groupe fonctionne c'est la préfiguration
d'un nouveau mouvement politique plus
large
selon le point d'ailleurs cette semaine
thierry solère prépare déjà un appel des
élus locaux à la constitution d'une
force nationale ce serait alors le
dernier acte du divorce entre de droite
qui semblent irréconciliables
évadez vous êtes d'accord d'autres
intérêts considérables c'est la
télévision parce que je vous expliquais
s'il n'y a pas d'un côté ce qui serait
constructif beau et intelligent
de l'autre ceux qui seraient destructif
moche et bêtes pardon mais c'est une
vision un poil caricatural consistant à
présenter des choses là des ckia 100
députés qui sont toujours membres d'un
groupe qu'on appelle le mont groupe
l'est républicain
nous sommes des députés libres
indépendants libres parfois de voter
ceux qui râlent dans le bon sens libre
de nous opposer lorsque nous penserons
que des propositions des manuels macro
et du gouvernement ne vont pas dans
l'intérêt national libre surtout de
rester une force de proposition nous
sommes 100 députés républicains libre et
de l'autre côté sur quête de l'autre une
force libre de s'opposer de voter de
proposer à s'opposer à tous et pas du
tout une ligne dure c'est une ligne de
liberté c'est comme ça que nous avons
fait campagne de nos territoires
c'est pour ça que nous sommes ici et
puis de l'autre côté vous avez 7 ou 8
personnes avec quatre cinq autres qui en
réalité sont candidats pour être sous
secrétaire d'état aux petits pois dans
un gouvernement philippe iii qui sont
prêts à tout à toutes les vilenies pour
essayer de plaire au pouvoir élyséen
pour entrer dans un gouvernement eurent
philippe iii comme ceux des forces et
constructive c'est le choix car
guillaume large et leur ligne ils ont
fait campagne là dessus ils ont fait
campagne souvent mettant majorité
présidentielle aux donc il faut les
exclure et il s'agit pas d' employer ces
mots exclure pas exclure il s'agit de
prendre mais veut des actes il s'agit de
prendre acte on est au début du
quinquennat
il va y avoir une clarification et à
titre personnel
j'entends bien moi prendre toute ma part
à cette clarification
je suis pas constructif entre guillemets
au sens soumis à l'elysée pas dû toucher
un député libre républicain mais je veux
être reconstructeurs
car je crois qu'ils à la reconstruction
de la droite qui doit être engagée
ça va pas prendre quatre jours ça va
prendre plusieurs mois peut-être même
plusieurs années
alors juste un mot sur une autre image
de la semaine l élection sans
contestation cette fois de françois de
rugy président de l'assemblée il ya
quelque chose de 10 normalement le
quatrième personnage de l'état est élu
le temps de la législature c'est à dire
ça quand mais le président du groupe
majorité richard ferrand a dit que ce
poste serait remet en jeu dans deux ans
et demi qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est constitutionnel c'est
une question très franchement d'affaires
sont opposés mais qui est totalement
secondaire si le président de
l'assemblée nationale souhaite remettre
en jeu son mandat à tout instant il peut
le faire il peut le faire dans une demi
heure il peut le faire dans deux ans
sinon on vit fait ce qu'il veut donc ces
deux là s'aiment pas ça me paraît une
question seconde pourquoi pas enfin j'ai
pas des visionnements trancher là dessus
qui préside pendant cinq ans pendant
deux ans et demi un petit peu ce qu'il
veut
si j'ose dire et en tout cas il a été lu
à ce stade président de l'assemblée
nationale pour la durée de la
législature
nous verrons ce qu'il choisit de faire
le moment venu alain guillaume larrivé
cette semaine il avait aussi du
mouvement au sénat où un nouveau groupe
a vu le jour celui de la république en
marche
composé à l'heure actuelle de 25
sénateurs pour son président françois
patriat qui est très proche inde
emmanuel macron l'objectif de ce groupe
et la clarification guillaume larrivé
est la république en marche a pour
ambition de présenter des candidats dans
tous les départements renouvelables en
septembre est ce que vous redoutez de
perdre notre majorité au sénat
je trouve tout à fait naturel que le
parti présidentiel ait un groupe au
sénat et du reste françois patriat est
un homme de qualité que je connais bien
qu'ils aient les bourguignons lui aussi
il est normal que le parti présidentiel
ait un gros préserver ce dont on a
besoin c'est de la clarté moi je
comprends très bien qu'on puisse
soutenir le président de la république
s'est totalement légitime ce que j'ai
beaucoup de plus de mal respectée ce
sont ces individus invertébrés qui selon
l'intérêt du moment change de camp le
matin l'après-midi et le soir on en a un
certain nombre en un certain nombre à
l'assemblée nationale on a une dizaine
ça j'ai beaucoup de mal moi j'aime la
clarté et j'ai même vous dire un mot un
peu datés je pense qu'il faut avoir en
politique le sens de l'honneur
il faut savoir où on habite on doit pas
changer de veste toutes les deux heures
françois patriat lui il est parfaitement
cohérent il donc d'un des premiers
chevaliers si je dis d'emmanuel macron
depuis deux ans très bien il a une
attitude qui est très digne il est le
premier des sénateurs en mélange revenir
situe son groupe au sénat
c'est tout à fait légitime on a besoin
de clarté les français ils envie de ça
aussi mais pour unir juste de hamacs et
or est ce que ça risque de vous coûter
la majorité est ce que vous craignez que
la droite en septembre perdre la
majorité au sénat
je ne sais pas vous répondre à cette
question je pense par ailleurs que le
sénat est une institution qui devrait
être profondément remanié j'ai écrit un
livre début de l'année qui s'appelle la
soumission pour que vive la nation je
suis pas complètement convaincu à titre
personnel de la valeur ajoutée
institutionnelle du sénat au sein de la
république française pardon de dire à
une journaliste éminente de public sénat
alors on va reverser ses fans bpa pour
son éclairage politique et parlementaire
et on poursuit en se projetant peu plus
loin dans la semaine puisque le congrès
est donc réuni lundi à versailles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le président de la république a donc
décidé de s'exprimer devant les deux
chambres du parlement réunies pour
présenter les grandes lignes de son
action future
problème cette intervention aura lieu la
veille de la déclaration de politique
générale du premier ministre
l'opposition critiquent la mise en scène
d'un pouvoir absolu
regardez ce sujet de quentin calmet et
julie hulin lundi emmanuel macron
devrait normalement avoir face à lui 9
125 parlementaires
seulement il pourrait bien trouver un
hémicycle un peu vide les centristes
philippe viguier et jean christophe
lagarde ont annoncé désir leur absence
dénonçant notamment une réunion inutile
et coûteuse
même son de cloche du côté de la france
insoumise puisque nous sommes convoqués
pour entendre le monarque présidentiel
s'exprimer puisque nous sommes convoquer
sans délai amy adultes pression de sa
bonne volonté à propos du débat
parlementaire
et bien nous nous rebellons et nous ne
nous soumettons pas nous n'irons pas le
front national sera lui bien présent à
ce rendez-vous républicain mais il
condamne la méthode
à droite les parlementaires ont
finalement décidé de ne pas boycotter la
convocation
tout en dénonçant une faute politique et
une présidence impériale
c'est une vision des institutions qui
est excessivement présidentialiste dans
un régime parlementaire et moi je pense
que ça affaiblit le premier ministre le
parti communiste a lui appelé à un
rassemblement lundi à 14 heures devant
la mairie de versailles contre ceux
qu'il nomme une dérive monarchique c'est
quoi pour vous guillaume larrivé cette
adresse aux parlementaires ce sera la
version française du discours de l'état
de l'union que présent présente pas que
prononce par exemple un président
américain
qu'est-ce que vous comment vous
interpréter ce discours je pense que
c'est pas du tout anecdotique c'est une
vraie évolution du régime souhaitait
dans le présent dans le public c'est ce
que j'appelle la présidence impériale
pourquoi la constitution et prévoit que
le gouvernement détermine et conduit la
politique de la nation c'est pour ça que
le premier ministre vient devant
l'assemblée nationale faire ce qu'on
appelle le discours de politique
générale c'est s'en est suivi d'un vote
parce que nous les députés nous avons le
pouvoir le 2
à de l'interpeller de le questionner le
gouvernement est responsable devant
l'assemblée nationale ça c'est la nature
profonde de notre régime
la vème république je peux pas faire une
manuelle macron c'est se saisir d'un
article de la constitution qui prévoit
plus de manière exceptionnelle au fond
le président peut venir parler devant
les députés les sénateurs au congrès
c'est arrivé deux fois une fois que
nicolas sarkozy au moment de la crise
financière une fois que françois
hollande au moment des attentats de 2015
plus de 1800 presse était tout à fait
possible depuis 2008 comme ça dans des
circonstances exceptionnelles parce que
le chef de l'état veut dire quelque
chose de particulièrement graves
la liddell est tout à fait différente
l'idée du président emmanuel macron
c'est de venir au tout début de la
législature au fond la première parole
politique la seule et première parole
politique devant le parlement
celle président de la république dans
une espèce de discours impérial que nous
n'allons pas du tout pouvoir questionner
interrogé interpellé ça sera suivi de
certains nombres de monologues n'y a pas
de dialogue possible dans nos
institutions entre le président et les
parlementaires
je sais pas si on explique suffisamment
clairement parce que hong kong va c'est
pas une question d'anecdotes s'agit pas
juste de dire c'est de la communication
pour emmanuel macron il ya un sujet de
fond une évolution institutionnelle
moi je pense qu'on ne doit pas dénaturer
le régime
on doit pas évoluer la présidence a
interdit hier et je pense que ce
discours au congrès mais aussi on y
reviendra
le choix des ordonnances mais aussi ce
qu'on a dit juste avant c'est à dire la
prise de contrôle de tous les postes de
l'assemblée nationale par l'elysée
toutes ces petites choses là le refus de
parler au journalisme 14 juillet au
prétexte dit l'elysée dans le journal le
monde d'hier soir que le président
n'aurait pour une pensée trop complexe
pour se prêter aux questions des
journalistes une stratégie l'hommage en
mieux moi je pense qu'on est dans une
évolution que j'appelle la présidence
impériale c'est à dire une évolution qui
est assez préoccupante et je pense qu'il
va falloir assez vite que jupiter
descente de l'olympe et atterrissent et
pour le premier ministre est ce que vous
diriez que c'est quoi c'est une
humiliation
je constate que le premier ministre mais
désormais moins qu'un collaborateur il
est le commentateur du discours
présidentiel c'est à lui de savoir s'il
a envie de faire cela qu'est ce que vous
allez dire du coup à edouard philippins
qui viendra quand même devant
l'assemblée nationale un hardi bien sûr
prononcé son discours de politique
générale
nous allons mardi et puis dès mercredi
avec les séances de questions
d'actualité faire notre job des députés
libres et indépendants interpellant
contrôlant le gouvernement et on va
surtout entrer dans le concret exemple
la cje ministre de l'économie des
finances bruno le maire a fait toute une
campagne lorsqu'il était de droite
paraît-il pour dire qu'il fallait
baisser massivement la salle gct son axe
de campagne mans des primaires
maintenant après avoir retourné sa veste
dans tous les sens il des ministres des
manuels macron il va augmenter la csg
voilà on va lui expliquer pourquoi
pourquoi est ce qu'il veut faire payer
20 milliards d'euros d'impôts
supplémentaires aux français
on va faire notre job concrètement
est-ce qu'on est l'assemblée nationale
et qu'on doit avoir la liberté
d'interpeller le gouvernement
ce qu'on peut pas faire que le président
la république c'est bien le problème de
ce congrès pour finir sur cette question
du congrès justement est ce que vous
comprenez que certains élus certains
députés et certains sénateurs aussi le
boycott
chacun fait ce qu'il veut on n'est pas
aux ordres de l'elysée on est invité à y
aller à titre personnel je suis jamais
trop partisan de musique de la chaise
irie pense que je pense que les français
nous ont eus président parce qu on
occupe le siège comprenne la parole donc
j'irai naturellement au congrès mais je
n'en pense pas moins si j'ose dire je
considère qu'il ya là une évolution
institutionnelle très préoccupante c'est
un très mauvais début du quinquennat que
cette dérive déjà impérialistes alors on
va terminer par le gros chantier de ces
prochaines semaines qui est donc lancé
la réforme du code du travail par
ordonnance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est donc arrivé à l'assemblée le
projet de loi qui habilite le
gouvernement à faire cette réforme par
ordonnance le texte a été adopté en
conseil des ministres ce mercredi il
fixe les grandes lignes de la réforme
les détails avec céline sélection
c'était son baptême du feu
muriel pénicaud face à un parterre de
journalistes pour présenter sa réforme
du code du travail est au menu trois
grands objectifs le premier clarifier
les règles entre la loi les branches et
l'entreprise pour s'adapter au mieux aux
spécificités de chaque entreprise
la ministre propose de redéfinir les
rôles ce qui ne laisse pas pour autant
la place à une inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes n'y aura pas de
code de travail entreprise voilà ça ni
queue ni tête
donc il ya des moments où il faut pas
aussi se faire parce qu'au pad le
principe d'aversion on croit que tout
est par dessus tout non la loi prime
simplement elle a pas vocation à
connaître la réalité de chacune des
trois millions d'entreprises il ya les
problèmes qu'elle peut pas régler et des
choses concrètes au niveau de la branche
des choses qu on adore niveau
l'entreprise
donc chacun à sa place et c'est
l'articulation de la loi de la branche
est l'entreprise qui fera un système
sain et qui fonctionne bien
deuxième objectif simplifier et
renforcer le dialogue social en
généralisant par exemple la fusion des
instances représentatives dans
l'entreprise comités d'entreprise
délégués du personnel et chsct
enfin le projet prévoit de sécuriser les
relations de travail entre les
employeurs et les salariés
la ministre entend notamment plafonner
les dommages et intérêts aux prud'hommes
une manière de rassurer les employeurs
et créer des emplois
un boulanger qui a cinq salariés en face
de lui mais non c'est nous un concurrent
il est obligé son chiffre d'affaires
baisse
il réduit d'un salarié et bien s'il n'a
pas bien formulé sa lettre de
licenciement
c'est à dire s'il a dit qu'il est ancien
mais qui n'a pas dit qui supprimait le
poste il peut être condamné aux
prud'hommes ça crée le sentiment auprès
de 700 artisans que lui n'en bougera
plus je peux vous dire que tous les gens
qui connaît une embauche non plus
et déco comme ça il y en a énormément
les consultations avec les syndicats
devrait encore durer tout l'été
la cgt a d'ores et déjà annoncé une
journée de mobilisation du 12 septembre
guillaume larrivé cette réforme du
travail à va dans le bon sens pour vous
elle me pose un problème majeur je pense
c'est une réforme hémiplégique
parce qu'au fond ce que fait le
gouvernement c'est de nous demander par
ordonnance de simplifier disons le code
du travail sur un certain nombre de
points qui sont bien connus les uns des
mythes et prud'homales les accords
d'entreprise tout ce qui vient d'être
dit ok et pendant ce temps là il ya
plusieurs sujets qui sont pas du tout
traités
le vrai sujet pour moi c'est aussi de
dire dans le même temps on veut
assouplir le code du travail
comment est ce qu'on fait pour que les
français et les françaises qui
travaillent durement soient récompensés
de leur travail
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
c'est un sujet majeur qui n'est pas
traitée dans ce texte je le regrette a
essayé par amendement non mais c'est pas
une question de loin pas loin c'est une
question de justice si on veut vraiment
défendre les français qui travaillent il
ya le sujet de l'assouplissement du
travail mais il ya aussi et surtout le
sujet de la diffusion des heures
supplémentaires et le sujet que j'ai un
cousin de rugby qui me paraît absolument
majeur du rsa je pense que un français
qui est en âge de travailler qui est
valide et qui est au rsa il doit plus
percevoir le rsa
s'ils refusent de travailler et vraiment
on va essayer d'introduire ces sujets
dans le débat paiement sur la société
manche a justement vous dit on va
essayer mais commet pas ce que vous
dites que les visées à la main surtout
est-ce que vous aurez les moyens de
déposer des amendements de faire
entendre votre voix en commission en
tout cas encore aux affaires sociales où
le débat commence alors ya un vrai sujet
de deux techniques et de procédures
parlementaires c'est qu'il s'agit d'une
loi d'habilitation et une loi
d'habilitation elle ne peut être amendée
s'agissant du champ de l'habilitation
que pour restreindre le champ de
l'habitation ses études à paris du suran
compose donc on est pardon d'être un peu
technique mais on est encore un peu dans
une seringue de procédure qui démontre
une nouvelle fois que l'elysée ait envie
que cette maison ici c'est une espèce de
chambre dans le dos les moyens ou les
clones dans marche à se contenteront de
dire amen
dès qu'il ya une proposition faite par
le gouvernement donc on va essayer
peut-être ça va être des articles
additionnels des propositions de lois
parallèle bref
pas par tous les moyens légaux
naturellement faire entendre notre voix
mais moi je crois vraiment que sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires pour les employés pour
les ouvriers pour les infirmières dans
les hôpitaux psy et sur cette question
du rsa
il faut vraiment qu'on fasse le job la
réforme du travail ça peut pas être
seulement l'assouplissement du code du
travail
ça doit aussi être des mesures je le dis
de justice sociale je le dis nous sommes
de droite nous sommes pas une droite
anti sociale nous sommes aussi une
droite sociale
on doit répondre concrètement à ce que
nous ont dit les travailleurs et les
travailleuses en france
lors de cette campagne électorale il
faut que le travail paie il faut que le
travail paie plus que le rsa il faut que
le travail des notamment avec les heures
supplémentaires
alors cette semaine un aussi la cour des
comptes a rendu l'audit commandé par le
premier ministre carton rouge pour les
finances publiques en très mauvaise état
dérapages confirmé pour le déficit en
il manque 8 milliards d'euros dans les
caisses
guillaume larrivé est ce que le
gouvernement des deux fils va devoir
mener une politique de rigueur tout cas
je constate que emmanuel macron comme
conseiller économique et fiscal de
françois hollande ces dernières années
et tout à fait qu responsable de ce
bilan absolument lamentable que la cour
des comptes vient de révéler jeudi
on l'avait dit d'ailleurs un ces
derniers mois on avait dit à plusieurs
reprises je crois sur ce plateau que les
gouvernements de françois hollande avait
signé de véritable chèque en bois en
multipliant les dépenses non financées
maintenant la facture des années
hollande
elle est présentée aux françaises et aux
français c'est pas faute de l'avoir dit
de l'avoir dénoncé
il va falloir en effet que le
gouvernement prenne un budget serré mais
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est la cour
des comptes première institution
financière à l'hiver première
institution financière du pays qui
expressis verbis comme on dit dis que
c'est un budget insincère qui a été
présentée et votée par la majorité
sortante alors maintenant on va pas
pleurer sur le lait renversé ce que je
souhaite c'est que ce soit pas les
français qui payent des impôts
supplémentaires gouvernement veut déjà
augmenter la csg de 20 milliards d'euros
on a explosé déficits publics il faut
prendre des mesures de correction oui
mais justement est-ce que vous pensez
que les collectivités locales vont payer
le prix fort vous faire les frais de
cette économie qui va ce salaire est
nécessaire il faut que le ministre de
budget explique quelles sont ses
intentions ce que je sais c'est
qu'évidemment cette facture des années
hollande il va bien falloir être en
capacité de la payer quelque part
j'espère qu'on va le faire dans des
conditions justes sur les collectivités
je pense que le vrai sujet qui est
devant nous c'est un sujet de justice
territoriale quand vous habitez en
puiser dans ma circonscription par
exemple dans le village de chant bugs
vous avez une dotation par habitant qui
est trois fois plus faible que la
dotation par habitant versée par le
gouvernement
à nice à strasbourg ou à lille c'est
profondément injuste alors les
technocrates du ministère de l'intérieur
le 10 mai dans les grandes villes il ya
des charges de centralité la vérité
c'est que dans nos territoires dans deux
villages ya des charges de ruralité donc
je crois que le vrai sujet katia c'est
de dire que dans l'ensemble des concours
financiers de l'état n'en grosso modo de
l' enveloppe de 100 milliards d'euros
qui sont répartis il faut qu'en veloppe
constante on branche plus le tuyau aussi
sur ces territoires ruraux périurbains
un vaste sujet dont on aura l'occasion
de reparler merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis merci katia est très bonne
semaine à tous
[Musique]